hey this is presh tollwacker lotteries
like the Mega Millions and Powerball can
sometimes have jackpots that exceed one
billion dollars
the odds of winning each Lottery are
about one in 300 million and each ticket
cost two dollars
theoretically you could buy all
combinations of tickets for 600 million
leaving you with a guaranteed winnings
of 400 million dollars
so this raises a question can you just
buy all the tickets and guarantee
yourself a huge payout
alas reality gets in the way of this
stream
one issue is the lump sum payment
another issue is that of shared winnings
and then a third issue is the Practical
issue of getting that many tickets
Final in this video I'll verify all the
odds are presented
so let's get started with the lump sum
payment
the jackpot of one billion dollars is
paid out in 30 equal yearly payments if
you want all the money up front it goes
down to about 50 to 60 percent so let's
just say optimistically it's 600 million
dollars
now if you have 600 million dollars in
winnings that exactly offsets all the
combinations you would need to put out
now this is ignoring all the smaller
prizes for matching some of the numbers
so it's not a complete analysis but you
can see right away the strategy of
buying all combinations isn't likely to
net you a lot of money
but there's another issue with this that
of shared winnings
so you get 600 million dollars in a lump
sum payment if you buy all combinations
let's say there are 120 million other
tickets sold
so we can calculate the number of
winners the probability of that
happening and your share of the price
so if there are zero other winners we
can calculate the probability is 67
percent and your share will be 100 of
the prize
but what if there is one other winner
the probability of this is 27 and your
share gets cut in half you have to share
this with the other winner and you only
get 50 percent
if there are two other winners the
probability of this happening is five
percent and your share is one-third
33.33 percent
now the probability of more than two
winners in this case is about one
percent and your share will be even less
so your expected share of the winnings
is 82 percent but in about 33 of the
cases you're going to be left splitting
the prize with someone else so you've
put up 600 million dollars but you're
not getting 600 million dollars back
that is a huge problem
furthermore as the jackpot size
increases the number of tickets sold
also increases because of the frenzy
so more realistically we might consider
that 300 million tickets are sold in
that case the number of winners being
zero has the probability of 37 percent
that's the chance you won't share it
with anyone else
the chance of one other winner is also
37 percent the chance of two other
winners is 18 and the chance of more
than two winners is eight percent so
here your expected share of the prize is
just 63 percent and in 63 percent of the
cases you're going to be sharing the
jackpot so you will definitely be out a
lot of money so let's just summarize
this we have a one billion dollar
jackpot which gets reduced to 600
million dollars if you take a lump sum
payment then it gets reduced further to
a 378 million dollar expected value of
split winnings however that doesn't
really capture the story because there's
a high chance that you're going to split
the prize and a high chance you'll be
out 300 million dollars or more
so if you spend 600 million to buy all
combinations you're looking at a 222
million dollar loss
so this is not a good strategy to pursue
now let's just say you ignore all these
odds and you still want to pursue the
strategy well you're still going to run
into some practical issues how are you
going to buy 300 million tickets
in order to get the numbers you want you
need to hand mark them so if you have
300 million tickets and you can mark
them at one minute per ticket assuming
you work eight hours per day this will
be 625
000 days to mark all of these numbers
so you're not going to be able to mark
them in a reasonable amount of time
between when the lottery is announced
and when it is drawn I'll now conclude
the video by verifying the odds
presented
in the Mega Millions lottery the odds of
winning are about 1 in 302 million the
lottery Works where you pick five
numbers from 1 to 70 without replacement
and the order does not matter you then
pick one number from 1 to 25.
so what are the total number of
combinations where you could pick five
numbers from 1 to 70. so we have five
slots the first slot can be 70 numbers
then 69 then 68 then 67 then 66. we
multiply these together to get all
permutations but the order doesn't
matter so we need to divide it by the
number of ways we can arrange five items
this will be five times four times three
times two times one which is equal to
120. the number of ways we can pick one
number from 1 to 25 is 25 so we take the
total number of permutations divide it
by 120 multiply it by 25 and we get
about 302 million
now this is a correct calculation
in order to do a shortcut we could just
do 70 choose five this is 70 factorial
divided by 65 factorial 5 factorial and
this is going to be about 12 million we
multiply this by 25 and that gets us to
about 302 million
the Powerball lottery Works slightly
differently the odds are 1 in 292
million
so you pick five numbers from 1 to 69
the order doesn't matter and then you
need to pick one number from 1 to 26. so
we have 69 choose 5 then we take 26
other numbers we multiply these together
and we get 292 million
now what about shared winnings let's say
t is equal to 300 million other tickets
sold
p is about 1 in 300 million that's the
probability of winning the lottery
so by the binomial theorem we have P
multiplied by winning plus 1 minus P
multiplied by losing we want this whole
thing raised to the power of T where T
is equal to 300 million
you can calculate the probability of X
by calculating the particular
coefficient of P raised to the power of
X multiplied by 1 minus P raised to the
power of T minus X and this is T choose
X but this is going to be very difficult
to calculate because T is a very large
number and P is a very small number so
what we're going to use is the poisson
approximation it works extremely well in
this type of case
so the probability of X is equal to e to
the power of negative Lambda multiplied
by Lambda to the power of X all over X
factorial and Lambda is equal to T times
P so in this case T times p is equal to
1. so the probability that X is equal to
zero just works out to be e to the power
of negative Lambda and this is about 37
percent the probability that X is equal
to one is equal to e to the minus Lambda
multiplied by Lambda to the power one
divided by one factorial and that's also
about 37 percent the probability that X
is equal to two is e to the power of
negative Lambda multiplied by Lambda
squared divided by two factorial and
this works out to be about 18 and that's
where those odds come from
so unfortunately there is a guaranteed
way to win the lottery but because of
these practical issues it's not a
guaranteed way to Win It profitably
thanks for making us go into the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
[Music]